hi YouTube my name is Dan Shapiro I
direct the Harvard international
negotiation initiative and it's a
wonderful experience being here at Davos
and it's wonderful experience to have
the opportunity to talk with you today
and to hear your feedback as well the
work I do is a negotiation conflict
resolution and what is the one issue I
see is most important in 2008 what are
plenty of them the one I'm particularly
focused on is how to deal with the
emotional and identity-based dimensions
of conflict looking around the world
right now as our world is shrinking it's
getting flatter and more globalized
people are interacting more and more and
that makes it more and more challenging
to try and get work effectively done and
ultimately what that means is that
emotions are going to become a potential
trouble point but at the same time they
can be one of your greatest lessons in
2008 what can we be most focused on I
would suggest we focus on the human
dimension of conflict and of human
interaction so for example as you are
interacting with other people in this
upcoming year in what ways can you try
to appreciate their perspectives even if
you strongly disagree with their
perspectives simply by officiating the
research is quite clear on this you are
able to enlist helpful emotions and you
and the other party that would get along
much more effectively whether you are a
head of state trying to negotiate a big
peace treaty or whether you are like
myself trying to negotiate with my wife
where to go on Friday night for dinner
so good luck with all of your
negotiations and pay particular
attention to the emotional dimension and
if you're interested in more information
my colleague Roger Fisher and I recently
wrote a new book on that subject called
beyond reason using emotions as you
negotiate and I also direct an
initiative you can check out the
initiative at our website just google
Harvard international negotiation
initiative you'll find us I look forward
to your feedback and to thinking through
your feei your ideas and to talking more
with you over YouTube thanks so much